en el vídeo anterior vimos que cuando
multiplicamos o dividimos cantidades con
cifras significativas o medidas el
resultado tendrá el mismo número de
cifras significativas que aquella
cantidad con el menor número de cifras
significativas que usamos para
multiplicar o dividir
hagamos un ejemplo rápido si yo tengo
2.000 por 3.5 mi resultado aquí sólo
puede tener tengo en esta cantidad tres
cifras significativas y aquí tengo dos
por lo que mi resultado que de hecho mi
resultado es 7 deberá tener dos cifras
significativas pongo 7.0 aquí ya tengo
mis dos cifras significativas ponemos el
cero después del punto decimal justo
para indicar que hay dos cifras
significativas con la suma y la resta
esto es un poco diferente
primero haré un ejemplo numérico y luego
pensaremos en un ejemplo más de la vida
cotidiana cuando sumamos o restamos los
dígitos o cifras significativas
no van a importar tanto como la
precisión real de las cosas que sumamos
o restamos cuántos lugares decimales
alcanzamos por ejemplo si yo sumar a
1.26 + 2.3 estas son medidas en la
primera llegamos hasta las centésimas
centésimas y tiene tres cifras
significativas esta segunda tiene dos
cifras significativas pero la medición o
la precisión sólo llegó hasta las
décimas si hacemos la suma nos va a
quedar 3.56 y aquí no contamos las
cifras significativas en su lugar
tenemos que sólo podemos tener la misma
precisión que aquella cantidad con la
menor precisión en este caso la de menor
precisión fue ésta donde medimos hasta
las décimas nada más es 2.3 esta de aquí
por lo que nuestro resultado solamente
llegará a las décimas va a llegar hasta
acá por lo que tenemos que redondear
este
6 es mayor que 5 por lo que voy a
redondear hacia arriba y aquí mi
resultado va a quedar 3.6 si nos
importan las cifras significativas así
es como va a quedar este resultado y en
este caso coincidió que el resultado
quedó con el mismo número de cifras
significativas que el operando con menor
cifras pero este no siempre es el caso
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora tengo un 1.26
más cientos 2.3 aquí tengo tres cifras
aquí tengo cuatro el resultado es
103 punto 56 pero nuestra respuesta no
debe tener tres cifras significativas
sino que deberá tener la misma precisión
que tiene la cantidad con la mínima
precisión que usamos para hacer este
cálculo aquí nuestra precisión llegó
hasta las centésimas y en este otro caso
nuestra precisión llegó solo a las
décimas así que en el resultado sólo
podremos llegar a las décimas hay que
redondear este seis es mayor que cinco
por lo que lo redondeamos hacia arriba
quiere decir que esto nos va a quedar
como 103.6 redondeamos hasta las décimas
porque las décimas fue hasta donde
llegamos en nuestra precisión de las
cantidades que usamos para encontrar
este resultado para ver por qué esto
tiene sentido
hagamos un ejemplo que involucra medir
algo tenemos aquí un bloque vamos a
dibujar un bloque más o menos así y aquí
tengo una buena regla que nos permite
medir hasta el centímetro más cercano
este bloque resultó que miden
punto 0 9 metros hasta acá y ahora
imaginemos que tenemos otro bloque pero
este bloque se midió con otra regla y
esta regla podría medir hasta el
milímetro más cercano este lado del
bloque midió 1.901 metros imaginemos que
estas medidas se tomaron hace mucho
tiempo y ya no podemos volver a tomar
estas medidas y alguien nos pregunta qué
tan alto llegarían si pusiéramos un
bloque encima del otro este bloque rojo
y encima pusiéramos este bloque azul
cuanto mediría esta torre bueno
si no nos interesará las cifras
significativas simplemente sumaríamos
los lados de las alturas queremos que
este azul me de 1.901 metros y el bloque
de aquí abajo mide 2.09 metros así que
podríamos hacer la suma 1.901 + 2.09
sería igual a 3.991 el problema con esta
cifra es que no representan bien la
precisión que se usó en la medición si
yo les dijera que la altura es de 3.991
metros implicaría que puede medir la
altura hasta la milésima más cercana y
la realidad es que solo puede medir una
parte de esta torre hasta la milésima
más cercana la otra parte sólo la pueda
medir hasta la centésima más cercana así
que mi resultado tendrá la precisión
hasta la centésima más cercana porque
así tendría menos error que toma en
cuenta en la medida de la milésima por
eso es que el resultado tendrá la
precisión de aquella medida con la menor
precisión en este
y el resultado deberá llegar a las
centésimas así que si llega a las
centésimas analizo este que es menor que
5 por lo que el redondeo va hacia abajo
y esta cantidad me queda como 3.99
metros además quiero aclarar que eso no
solo aplica cuando tenemos un punto
decimal imaginemos que vamos a medir un
edificio imaginemos que medimos un
edificio y éste mide 350 metros de
altura y decimos que hay una persona que
instala torres torres para poner antenas
y él ha medido sus antenas hasta el
metro más cercano y dice que su torre
mide 8 metros de alto y para clarificar
estas medidas del edificio es ambigua
porque no estoy indicando cuántas cifras
significativas hay quizás se me dieron
exactamente 350 metros o quizá se
redondeó hasta la decena más cercana una
mejor manera de representar lo sería en
lugar de usar estas cifras y tal cual
poner 3.5
por 10 a la 2 metros de alto la notación
científica hace que sea más fácil
identificar las cifras significativas en
este caso son 2 otra forma de describir
esto sería poner 350 con una barrita
arriba o abajo indicando hasta donde se
llegó en la medición cualquiera de esas
formas sirven para indicar las cifras
significativas aunque la más común es la
notación científica asumiendo que se
midió hasta la decena de metro más
cercano qué tan alto sería el edificio
con la torre de antena es su primer
impulso quizás será el sumar las
cantidades directamente el edificio esto
lo pongo por acá el edificio más la
torre me dirían 350 más 8 serían 358
metros pero de nuevo estaremos
representando mal la precisión dando la
impresión de que pudimos medir la
combinación hasta el metro más cercano
cuando sólo la torre fue la que se pudo
medir hasta el metro más cercano para no
y representar la medida con el nivel de
precisión real tenemos que redondear
esto hasta la decena de metros más
cercano en este caso tenemos 358 este 8
es mayor que 5 por lo que el redondeo va
hacia arriba y esto nos queda como 360
metros y esto se ve ambiguo mejor
pongamos aquí en la rayita arriba o
abajo para indicar que estás aquí donde
se tiene la precisión o las cifras
significativas o también lo podemos
expresar como 3 puntos 6 por 10 a la 2
metros que indica sin lugar a dudas que
hay dos cifras significativas